comme la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire cette semaine
c'est le salon de l'agriculture et comme
chaque année la période des belles
promesses mais que se passe-t-il
réellement dans nos campagnes une
compétitivité agricole qui s'effondre au
point que notre balance commerciale est
devenue difficile du jamais vu
des filières dans la tourmente comment
nous betteraviers peuvent-ils comprendre
qu'ils n'auront aucune possibilité pour
protéger leur culture contre la jaunisse
cette année pendant que les pays
européens qui nous entourent pourront
eux utiliser des produits foliaires
interdit chez nous et je pourrais vous
citer bien d'autres exemples
des filières animales pas assez
rémumatrice avec pour conséquence un
cheptel français qui font comme neige au
soleil
des coûts de production qui explosent le
matériel les engrais l'énergie la main
d'oeuvre et des prix de vente qui eux ne
suivent pas malgré Galline 1 et égaline
de nombreuses exploitations ne trouvent
plus de repreneurs aujourd'hui alors que
la moitié des fermes abricoles de notre
pays sont à renouveler dans les 10 ans
qui viennent la situation est grave et
n'oubliez jamais que rien n'est pire
qu'une crise alimentaire pour un pays
monsieur le ministre les agriculteurs
n'en peuvent plus des discours et les
promesses c'est du concret qu'ils
veulent aujourd'hui que comptez-vous
faire pour enrayer le déclin de notre
agriculture française
je vous remercie